Pues sí efectivamente ha sido una
audiencia relativamente rápida como se
esperaba de hecho ha llegado una hora
antes de lo previsto el exmandatario a
este edificio de la corte Federal allí
ha entrado por un por un acceso
subterráneo en una estacionamiento para
luego tomarse las fotografías y las
huellas dactilares después ha empezado
esa audiencia donde se le han leído
formalmente los 37 cargos a los que se
enfrenta 31 de ellos son relacionados
con la ley de espionaje de Estados
Unidos que tiene que ver con la
retención de documentos clasificados de
información sobre defensa nacional hay
que destacar que es encontrar un 31
documentos en su residencia Privada de
mar al agua Aquí en Florida y algunos de
esos documentos estaban marcados como
secretos o Ultra secretos sólo por el
hecho de tener esos documentos ya son
se pueden hacer servir para impu
tar a estos delitos como ha sido aquí en
las afueras de esta corte Federal se han
concentrado numerosas personas que han
querido expresar su apoyo al
expresidente Donald Trump con banderas
también con gorras y mensajes diciendo
que todo esto forma parte de un
Movimiento Político contanos Anthony se
espera que hable hoy Donald Trump habrá
algún pronunciamiento
Sí de hecho teníamos la esperanza de que
el presidente el expresidente Donald
Trump diera algunas declaraciones a su
salida de esta corte no ha sido así ya
ha salido de estas instalaciones rumbo
al aeropuerto de Miami para tomar un
avión a Nueva Jersey y está previsto que
sea allí en un evento de recaudación de
fondos donde pueda pronunciar un
discurso y hablar sobre algunas tener
reacciones del propio Trump sobre este
proceso penal que acaba de producirse en
estos momentos aquí en Miami la que sí
que ha hablado ha sido una de las
abogadas representantes del Donald Trump
esa línea Java que aquí en los
exteriores ha dicho que esto no se trata
de las elecciones de 2024 que esto no es
un Movimiento Político ha dicho que esto
se basa en el objetivo es destruir los
principios básicos de este país dice con
estas palabras se mostraba en contra por
supuesto de este proceso penal que está
enfrentando a Donald